the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so as a quick review of all the
different biological effects we've
pretty much taken it up to here we've
explained the physical and chemical
stages of what happens when radiation
interacts with mostly bags of water with
some solutes and them better known as
organisms at dynamic equilibrium
everything from this sort of femtosecond
level ionization of water almost
certainly because that's most of what
biological things are - the formation of
many many many many many different
radiolysis byproducts eventually that
end up as just a few that we care about
the one longer-lived radio lytic
byproducts that will then diffuse away
from the original damage cascades and go
on to eat something else likely DNA or
something that you don't want to get
oxidized or chemically changed we talked
a little bit about radiolysis in
reactors and how you can actually
measure it directly which was only done
really a few years ago which is pretty
cool just to remind you of this
experiment there's a tiny high pressure
cell of high pressure high temperature
water there's a foil sample with a very
thin region and protons firing through
it so that they both are radiate the
sample and induce radiolysis and the
water at the same time and this way you
can test the effect of radiolysis in the
water here versus just plain old high
pressure high temperature corrosion here
and the results are pretty striking or
you can clearly see the boundary where
the proton beam was as well as the
increased thickness of the oxide and
corrosion layer formed when radiolysis
is turned on so to speak we went through
DNA damage and we ended with
pseudoscience so I want to bring up a
couple no we don't have time for that
but we we spent the last 15 minutes of
class railing against pseudoscience and
making sure that you check your facts
but we pointed out a number of things
wrong with some of the studies so aside
from just that guy miss reading
everything on that entire blog of the
studies that you felt weren't very
convincing what do you remember about
them some of those studies were totally
fine but some of them were not
that's what I was hoping some would say
yeah the case study of four women who
got breast cancer in the pocket where
they held their cell phones for right or
in a study of 29 humans 11 of them got
brain tumors here it's pretty easy to
cherry-pick small amounts of data
I want did want to say that just because
radiofrequency photons aren't ionizing
doesn't mean they can't hurt you if
you've ever no no one's ever been inside
a microwave I wonder if anyone's ever
felt the effects of an external
microwave beam by something like this
the Active Denial system one of my
favorite weapons ever because it doesn't
actually permanently hurt anyone it just
heats up the outer layer of your skin it
fires these non ionizing photons at RF
frequency and effectively makes you feel
like you're on fire so if there's a
whole mess of troops charging at you
let's say at the DMZ from North and
South Korea all you've got to do is turn
on this thing and they all think they're
on fire because their body is sending
them signals that I'm on fire and then
you turn it off and they're okay so no
loss of life no permanent damage a lot
of maybe psychological but whatever
can't see that and Active Denial system
great name for it isn't it yeah I think
non-lethal weapons are really the way of
the future is just make it make it
unpleasant to engage in warfare and
people probably won't but then no one
has to get hurt which is nice
well then on to the sources of data
because like Sarah said sample size is
everything especially when you're trying
to figure out our small amounts of
radiation bad for you this simple
question hasn't really been answered
suitably yet and that's because thank
God we don't have enough people exposed
too small but measurable amounts of
radiation to draw meaningful conclusions
from this data I think that's a good
thing is if we were certain about
whether small amounts of radiation like
1 millisievert could cause cancer then
there would have been millions or
billions of people exposed and so it's
kind of a good thing that they weren't
but the sources of this data the first
source was radium dial workers like you
may have heard of the folks that would
lick the paint
Rush's with glow-in-the-dark radium
watches they ended up setting the first
occupational limit for dose because they
were the first large group to be exposed
to radiation in a controlled setting
things like uranium miners radon
breathers better known as us but
especially folks that smoke anything
medical diagnostic so anyone that gets a
medical procedure you can follow up with
them to find out what's let's say the
extra incidence of cancer and figure out
if you have a high dose rate medical
procedure does it and do secondary
cancer down the line but like we said
last time down the line is the key here
I take a whole bunch of radiation now if
it was going to save my life now and
maybe make it messed up in 20 years
because then you get 20 more years of
life or however long you get and then
from accidents survivors of the atomic
bombs not just the folks at the
epicenter but in the whole Fallout
regions in nearby as well as nearby
nuclear accidents and the criticality
events like the diamond core that you
guys analyzed on the exam luckily there
aren't a lot of those either but they
were pretty severe the ones that got
exposed and speaking of accidents has
anyone ever heard of the kyshtym
disaster this is the third worst nuclear
accident that we know of in history
after Chernobyl and Fukushima and worse
than Three Mile Island because Three
Mile Island was an almost accident there
was some partial melting of the core
there was almost no release of
radioactivity and the definition of a
nuclear accident and the public sense is
release of radioactivity there's
actually two quantities that folks in PR
a or probabilistic risk analysis are
most interested in has anyone heard of
these terms CDF and lourve core damage
frequency and large early release
frequency the all the fancy probability
fault trees and everything goes into
calculating the probability that the
core gets damaged so that could be an
accident in one write or the probability
of a radioactivity release and that is
an accident so if no one's ever heard of
this there's a city in Russia I don't
know why it says roofs lund maybe came
from a different language called kyshtym
where they had the Maya clear and
reprocessing plant and there was a tank
full of radioactive way
that was exploded it was a chemical
explosion but full of strontium all
sorts of other radionuclides
that blew up with about a hundred tons
worth of TNT and ended up contaminating
a rather large area with this plume
called the I think it's called the East
Chelyabinsk radioactive twice or the
early what is it the South South
something Urals radioactive trace and
that area still contaminated today
because the disaster was covered up or
rather wasn't nothing was said these
towns here they didn't I weren't
actually towns back in 1957 when this
happened they were just given
designations like Chelyabinsk forty or
chillier been sixty-five because the
largest nearby city was Chelyabinsk and
the villages nearby were just numbered
so that was just the postcode for the
secret nuclear city the US had a few
Russia had something like a hundred
twenty and they still have a lot of
cities where entry is restricted or it's
still awfully difficult to go there like
when you have to declare we're and
Russia are you going to get a visa if
you say one of these cities there's
going to be some questions and this is
where I'm going best possible logo for a
conference being held in Siberia in
February right on the end right on the
edge in this town called kyshtym the
nearest town to the MIAC plant so I'll
be taking my camera I don't know if I'll
be allowed to use it but we're gonna
find out anyway it's being held in a
sanatorium and does anyone know what a
sanatorium is like I'm honestly asking a
question I don't know what a sanatorium
is or why the nuclear conference is
being held there but it should be pretty
cool so yes Iberia in February right
near the South Urals radioactive tracer
should be interesting
the first group of folks that were
exposed were the people painting radium
watch dials and the reason radium was so
damaging is because radium is in the
same column of the periodic table as
calcium it's a bone seeking element so
which of the tissues do you think would
be most damaged by ingestion of radium
bones what part of the bones
specifically the marrow the rapidly
dividing part of the bones if you
remember from the I don't have it on
this presentation but the relative
tissue factors for different tissues the
hard part of the bone is a point zero
one it's basically like a nobody cares
bone marrow however is a different story
because it's always rapidly dividing
producing red blood cells platelets
lymphocytes it's it's making your blood
the solid portion of your blood and so
it's a pretty important tissue
so get radium anyone else oh no what
does radium tend to emit which kind of
particles if you had to take a guess
yeah alphas it's a pretty heavy element
it emits alphas and alphas have that
radiation quality factor of twenty
meaning alphas have very short range but
they're the most damaging type of
radiation when ingested so this was
really bad news there was a lot of
incidence of illness and cancer from
folks painting radium watch dials and
then the first data from bones after
death because there were a lot of those
established how much radium were you
allowed to get exposed to this came out
to about 0.6 milligram anyone have any
idea what that would be in millisieverts
per week with a quality factor of twenty
and a bone marrow factor of about 0.12
yeah on the order of like singles of
millisieverts per week
not bad anyone know how much dose you
typically get in a year in background
yeah it's few millisieverts a year yeah
so this was the first occupational
safety limit for radiation risk it is
actually it comes out to larger than 50
millisieverts per year which is what the
normal occupational workers are allowed
how about your radiation workers what's
your limit five REM which comes out 250
millisieverts per year okay there you go
large population sizes that do exist
that get a whole lot of radiation
however is anyone that smokes and
anything because when you take plant
matter which has a high surface area
concentrate it so anything that it
brings up from the roots in the soil or
that settles out on the leaves in the
air gets concentrated in the dry
fraction and then gets burned and
inhaled a lot of those heavy metals that
are radon byproducts and such are fairly
reactive they'll stick around in your
tissues and give you a whole lot of
alpha dose so when you have populations
of people who have or haven't smoked you
actually can figure out the number of
extra attributable deaths to things like
indoor radon depending on if you live in
a smoky atmosphere or not and so to
distinguish the types of biological
effects that we're worried about we can
group these into two there's short term
effects which manifest themselves in
hours days or weeks we'll call that
immediate and then there's long term
effects which tend to manifest in short
shortest years and longest decades so
things like acute radiation sickness is
due to rapid cell death of a few
different kinds over time and which kind
depends on the route of exposure the
isotope the type of radiation and the
total amount of dose to those tissues
and if you guys of all what are some of
the symptoms of acute radiation sickness
like did anyone read what happened to
the folks in the demon core
hair fell out what else vomiting
diarrhea all the fun ones yeah well I
will explain why these sorts of things
happen with acute radiation exposure now
if you don't get that much radiation
exposed but you do get enough to mutate
cells you have what's called delayed
somatic effects anything from cancer to
straight-up mutations to birth defects
any sort of permanent and reproducible
modification to a cells DNA that can
induce mutations so let's first talk
about the short-term effects because
they're a little easier to understand
and because the doses were much higher
you don't need as much of a population
size in order to figure out did this
effect did this amount of dose have an
effect so for things up to a quarter of
a gray pretty much nothing happens
that's quite a toasty dose for gammas
that would be like getting five times
your occupational yearly limit
instantaneously yeah this is not
something you'd want to happen but it's
not going to cause any significant ill
effects up to a gray you'll start to see
a few symptoms like nausea and anorexia
they probably tend to go together if
you're feeling gastrointestinal e
horrible you probably don't want to eat
much and you will see things like bone
marrow damage like we talked about with
the radium workers fewer red white blood
cells less platelets also means easier
to bleed so a lot of the effects of
radiation damage are not primary they're
secondary just like most radiation
damage to cells itself is not damage to
the DNA but it's radiolysis of the water
nearby the DNA and eventual chemical
migration to cause damage to the DNA
chemically in this case it's not like
radiation takes out your platelets
radiation takes out the cells that
create the platelets the bone marrow
meaning that platelets if they live
about three weeks you'll tend to see a
drop in platelet count when your
production system gets lower this should
sound strikingly similar to series
radioactive decay because the same
equations can be used to model it let's
say you have a normal stable platelet
count I'm not gonna get on the board I
told you guys we wouldn't get too
deriving anymore but you've got some
source of platelets which would be your
bone marrow and you've got some sink of
platelets which would be normal cell
death so let's say there's a half-life
or a lifetime of platelets if you kill a
little bit of the source then you'll see
the sink start to decay but the source
will start to grow back over time from
cell division and you'll see the level
pop back up again and you can model it
with the same first order linear
ordinary differential equations same OD
es as series radioactive decay you can
use to guess how many platelets you
should have in your body at any time
following a certain dose 1 2 3 Gray's
when things get bad from go too bad from
worse pretty quick nausea and/or Exia
and infection tell me why do you think
infection results from radiation damage
yeah let's say your hair everything yeah
front to back let's hear it yep the
immune system is compromised what else
everyone gonna say the same thing okay I
have another story so I agree with you
guys but it also has to do with these
platelets anytime anything happens to
you ever cells tend to die you clap your
hands you probably kill a few cells you
bump into something you probably kill a
few cells you swallow some metal
shavings you're gonna kill a lot of
shell cells but your body has got mucous
membranes and all sorts of things and
platelets in order to repair that damage
all of a sudden if your blood thins out
and can start leaking from different
places or it's a lot harder to repair
like physical leaks in your body
bacteria can get in
so the normal amount of bacteria you're
exposed to every day which is enormous
there's theorized to be something like
ten times as many bacterial cells in
your body as human cells they're all
over the place they're just a lot
smaller well they can get into places
that they wouldn't normally get in so
what would normally be a pinprick and a
simple immune response with a suppressed
immune system and a lower platelet count
becomes a much more dangerous thing you
could undergo something called sepsis
that's basically blood turning to sewage
because you get a massive blood
infection
this is again let's say a secondary or
even a tertiary effect but very real
Hamada logic damage more severe Hema
refers to blood that's basically saying
the same thing recovery probable though
not assured why probable and why not
assured that's true everyone reacts
differently it also matters how much
treatment you get so if you get a crazy
compromised immune system we have
hospitals and you know sterile bubbles
and all sorts of things that you can be
put in but if you don't get to a
hospital in time to reduce the onset of
massive infection that's what could
happen then you go higher three to six
gray everything is above plus diarrhea
deep elation hair loss temporary
sterility think the temporary sterility
one's obvious why do you think diarrhea
and hair loss would occur
yeah exactly yeah any the most sensitive
cells are the ones that are rapidly
dividing to make you know villi and stem
cells in your intestines hair follicles
gonads anything that's dividing all the
time is going to feel the effects of
radiation damage much more severely and
barring any mutation which may take a
long time to manifest the wrong damage
of DNA and the cell just can't divide so
it dies and if those cells die then that
means that you can't uptake nutrition
and you just body just flushes
everything out in diarrhea fatalities
will occur in the range of three and a
half gray without treatment and this is
what's called the typical ld50 does
anyone know what an ld50 is the lethal
dose for right so about 50% of the
people exposed to 3.5 grey will die this
doesn't take into account difference in
treatment difference in person or
everything it's all together and I'll go
into one and ld50 for different things
is in a second and then over six gray
you get immediate incapacitation hits
the nervous system you get so many cells
leaking out that the chemical signals
for your neurons sodium and potassium
and other ions well if all your cells
die and leak out that all of a sudden
you're flooded with the ions that are
normally kept in a very careful
equilibrium to signal so you can
actually get sudden unconsciousness in a
matter of seconds to minutes from doses
over ten great so you just you just go
out like a light like that and may not
recover what's an ld50 it's the on it's
whenever an effect gets an onset by 50
percent of the population and there are
different something-something 50 doses
depending on let's say whether
something's therapeutic toxic or lethal
the example I like to give is selenium
anyone know anything about selenium in
the diet it's one of those trace
minerals that you need to survive but
can also kill you so below if you need
to get about on average five micrograms
of selenium in order to produce certain
enzymes that keep things going in the
body five micrograms is not a lot but
you know that in order to have a little
bit of selenium it's got a therapeutic
effect once you get around five
micrograms
most people will see some sort of
biological benefit if you get five
milligrams starts to become toxic this
is the case with pretty much anything
vitamins anyone ever had that's probably
gonna be an O anyone ever eaten Rossi a
liver before the polar bear livers I
don't know no one's gone up way way up
north anyway and you know why or indeed
vitamin A something that you need a
whole lot of to survive it's so
concentrated in the livers of seals and
polar bears that if you were to just eat
a polar bear liver you would die of
vitamin A poisoning so I didn't hear all
those things at once one at a time just
take a little taste you know it's all
about the amount right what were you
guys saying well no it's not like you
take a taste and you die again it's all
about the amount of exposure one little
taste is not gonna flood your system
with vitamin A but you eat an entire
polar bears liver you're gonna have a
bad day what I don't know why polar
bears have so much vitamin A no idea
actually but then beyond that you can
get lethal effects where you might get
sick from eating too much of something
but then again you know anyone ever
heard of the old hold your Wii for a
week contest where we found out really
the ld50 of water yeah so you drink way
too much water without any other solutes
you deplete your body from electrolytes
and then you can also die so I ran into
this experience personally I don't have
to ask any of you guys went hiking with
my dad in Nepal in 2009 in the last
vacation I've taken that's a long time
ago it's kind of cool at MIT it's fun
enough here that I haven't felt like
I've needed a vacation in what like
seven years I'm actually kind of taking
one this year because I'm going
somewhere for research and just sticking
around but when hiking in Nepal I ate
something I probably shouldn't in fact
everyone eventually ate something they
probably shouldn't and I had what could
be described as massive GI syndrome
Delhi Belly whatever you want to call it
my brother likes to call it poop and
mouth disease
because sanitation and stuff is not the
best there and so I was in a pretty bad
state and instead of drinking water to
replenish all of the water that was
leaving of every direction from the body
drinking salt water we took tablets that
had the same isotonic concentration of
electrolytes amino acids as those being
lost by the body because when water goes
in the body everything
osmotic aliy equilibria if you take in
lots of pure water it with a little bit
of sodium potassium other electrolytes
will dissolve into that water if it's
going out in any direction it's gonna
leave your body depleting you of
electrolytes so I had seven wonderful
days lying in bed drinking about a liter
of warm saltwater every 15 minutes or so
in order to maintain not just the water
but the electrolytes that your body
needed freaky huh yeah it was a great
vacation is there any wonder why I don't
want to take another one if I go back
there I'm having nothing but Clif bars
now it's hard to say no when folks that
live up in the mountains offer you what
little food they have but you should
really say no for your own safety anyway
yeah there's an ld50 for water by any
mechanism from electrolyte depletion to
there was a contest on the radio called
hold your Wii for a Wii when the
Nintendo Wii came out they said how much
water could you drink without going to
the bathroom and someone's bladder
exploded right yeah that's what I heard
either it would be a bladder explosion
or an electrolyte depletion so whatever
the mechanism the ld50 just tells if
somebody if a population in just a
certain amount of something or takes in
a certain amount of radiation how much
will cause 50% to die or for much lower
doses 50% will see some therapeutic
effect by any mechanism it doesn't
distinguish by mechanism so the four
phases of radiation damage this is where
all those Latin and bio roots really
come in handy the prodromal phase is the
initial symptoms of exposure which may
or may not happen one to three days
after exposure for massive exposure
you're not going to see this because
you're not going to live one to three
days for very minor exposure you may not
even see
these prodromal effects like a drop in
blood cell count or GI syndrome because
the dose might not be severe enough for
your body not to be able to cope with it
the latent phase this is the tricky one
an apparent recovery from the prodromal
systems so getting a medium dose of
radiation let's call that like 2 to 5
grey will cause some nausea vomiting and
headache and then you get better and
then you get worse in the manifest
illness phase because a lot of the
things that radiation will do can be
immediate if you suddenly cause the body
to release serotonin and induce the
vomiting reflex that goes away once that
serotonin is consumed or dealt with I
don't know how the body would deal with
it you might think you're getting better
but the cells that divide rapidly have
still incurred that damage and you won't
see that damage until they fail to
divide in their normal amount of time so
gee things like GI syndrome and hair
loss might not show up for a few days
afterwards because it's not like your
hair will just instantly fall out like
there's some cell that is holding on to
your hair follicle and then will just
release it when irradiated but those
follicles won't continue to produce the
keratin at the same rate or in a
different way or I can't speak that
intelligently about exactly the
mechanism of hair loss but it will take
a little bit of time to get there and
the final phase is a binary do you
recover or do you die could take days
two months two years to figure that out
these weren't in the reading but I
wanted to pull some much better tables
about what happens in each of these
phases as a function of radiation dose
so when does vomiting onset there are
actually patterns to be seen here so for
mild it may take a couple of hours after
exposure you may not stimulate the
immediate release of the hormones that
induce vomiting but then as the dose
gets more and more severe could be
anywhere from hours to less than 10
minutes so you can use the onset of
things like vomiting diarrhea headache
loss of consciousness and severe cases
to gauge the amount of dose someone has
absorbed in some unknown accident
because it's not like if you're in some
severe nuclear accident and you don't
happen to be wearing a very large
dosimeter how do you know how much dose
you got and how do you know how to treat
the person time can be your best weapon
there because except for very lethal
doses where you could go unconscious in
seconds or minutes you've got some time
hours two days to treat what happened
and if you can say all right I know the
time of exposure and I know the time of
onset of headache of diarrhea of
vomiting you can figure out roughly
maybe within plus or minus a grey how
much dose you had and what to treat
there are probably smarter ways of doing
this but with nothing else you've got
time as a variable to help you figure
this out why do you guys think that your
body temperature would go up upon
exposure to huge amounts of radiation
what's with the fever what does a fever
were a response to could it be a
response to
infection so any sort of sudden massive
infection would mount an immune response
and that would cause a fever because
you've got all sorts of cells doing
things expending energy trying to rid
your body of the infection what else
okay something for you to read up on for
the not for the home okay for the
practice homework the one that I can't
make do because it's after the last day
of classes what about let's see headache
I don't think we've explained that well
we'll get into the diarrhea stuff let's
go into the latent phase what tends to
happen well it looks like you get better
but blood work will tell you otherwise
and you can then tell how much dose you
were exposed to after a certain amount
of time by things like lymphocyte and
granulocytes
different immune system blood cells also
platelets also all sorts of other things
you can tell by a drop in certain blood
cell levels how much dose you've had and
you can sustain a certain drop in
platelets and immune cells without any
ill effects something like 30 to 40
percent your platelets could go away
you're not haemophiliac temporarily
you're still gonna be okay can form
blood clots and result rows of what is
it responds to a nosebleed or a bruise
and these things aren't going to be
life-threatening diarrhea for low doses
you don't really get any so it looks
like intestinal cells may be a little
bit more robust than bone marrow except
with really severe doses you'll start to
see that pop up once those cells fail to
divide once let's say the existing villi
die-off new ones don't replace them and
you lose your ability to uptake
nutrition and then depilation hair loss
beating you know beginning on day 15 or
later you might think you're out of the
woods and then all of a sudden your hair
starts to fall out and that will help
tell you about how much dose you've had
once again and then the critical phase
what happens when things go from bad to
better to worse how quickly does this
happen
you tend to get things like infections
more severe infections disorientation
on longer times like seven days your
platelet count
pretty proportional to dose same thing
with number of lymphocytes lower and
lower and lower and then the onset time
is smaller and smaller and then you can
see the lethality of these different
doses depending on the person the
treatments a susceptibility any sort of
pre-existing conditions which you might
not know you have a question cancer yeah
radiation doses are pretty intense
so the dosed of a tumor for example in
proton therapy which is the only one
I've really read about can be in the
killa grey level but the idea there is
you fried the tumor you kill it soon
like you go beyond the lethal dose for
those cells while inducing much less
damage in the rest of the rest of the
surrounding person that's the nice cork
of protons is you can do that in a very
narrow range the straggle on 250 MeV
proton beams is on the order of like you
know microns less than millimeters which
is pretty cool but a lot of the hair
loss can come from the chemotherapy
chemotherapy is better known as poison
it's just a poison that effects tumor
cells slightly more strongly than the
rest of your cells but it is nasty stuff
and it's the chemo that can cause the
hair loss as well yeah so would you
attribute the hair loss to radiation or
to chemo I would say chances are it's
chemo depending on where the tumor is I
mean if you have a localized proton beam
coming in to treat a tumor there there
you're not gonna get much hair loss up
here but chemo penetrates throughout the
whole body as far as if you're getting
x-ray therapy of a brain tumor that I
don't know I really haven't looked into
that so good question and then the time
and severity of these symptoms well this
is something I'd like you guys to read
on your own because it's tons of words
on a screen but it's something I suggest
you read it's not done that carefully in
the reading which is why I provided it
here for you in the slides then going on
to what these radiation symptoms mean I
wanted to translate a little bit of the
Latin Greek whatever routes into
something you can understand these
hamato poetic symptoms anything to do
with the blood decreased platelets
immune suppression all that kind of
stuff and the origin is the stem cell
system in your bone marrow breaks down
and you don't make as much of all the
components of blood as you normally
should the gastrointestinal comes from
the stem cells in the villi those high
surface area structures in your
intestines that absorb the nutrition
which are also normally covered in a
thick layer of mucus to keep all the
bacteria from getting out because
nutrients like let's say minerals or
small proteins are a hell of a lot
smaller than bacteria they can diffuse
or transport through the mucus much
faster so you can uptake the nutrition
and not let the bad stuff in and the
neuro or cerebrovascular stuff is
straight up blasting of endothelial
cells your let's say yeah I think that
skin cells a term called edema which is
fluid leakage has anyone ever seen
pictures of folks with massive edema in
the legs like folks at let's say haven't
gone out of bed for years and their legs
swell up like this
that's just fluid leaking into the
intracellular spaces I'd say take a look
I don't think I'm gonna show pictures of
it cuz it's kind of nasty on the screen
but if you want to know what edema looks
like then I suggest you look it up
there's plenty of horrific stuff on
Google Images and so what happens in
these hematopoietic cells about one gray
can knock out about a third of your bone
marrow cells and that's actually okay
because those surviving cells are
redefining quite quickly and that means
that you won't have that much of a drop
in blood cells because let's say you
kill off a bunch of the bone marrow
cells but they read avise in a shorter
life time than let's say the red blood
cells or platelets live you're not going
to see that much of a dip in the blood
cell levels which are ultimately your
main line of defense against sepsis
things like destruction of bone marrow
yeah that would that would be a bad
thing there's a whole lot of words here
I'd say this is better for you to read I
want to go through an explanation of
some pictures of what tends to happen to
in this case mouse bone marrow tissue
after a lethal dose 9.5
gray that's what it looks like
beforehand that's what you're left with
is very very few cells so that would be
definitely what a lethal dose looks like
because the ability to make all the
things that bone marrow makes has been
almost eliminated in this tissue so a
visual of what these sorts of things
look like for the gastrointestinal
systems I'm going to skip right ahead
and show you what healthy and irradiated
villi tend to look like so I've been
does anyone not know what I mean but I
say villi okay good so the little high
surface area structures in your
intestine that are normally great
absorbers of nutrition mostly due to
their surface area but also due to their
structure and their biological function
and you tend to kill those off with a
fair bit of radiation so this is what it
looks like after four days and seven
days and then twelve days things can
recover so they don't kill all the cells
they will divide and they will recall
curve as Amanda allow for that natural
healing to take place then you can
survive an acute dose of radiation so
when we talk about why do you need
hospital treatment it's basically to
stand in for your body's normal
functions while your body regenerates
those functions but for extremely severe
cases let's go back to that table of
hominid let's say leukocytes or whatnot
you have or lymphocytes if you get down
to the zero level you've completely
knocked out your body's ability to
produce those you might have a few cells
left here there but at that point
there's not much anyone can do but make
you comfortable and then in this case I
think this was a human one yeah okay so
a healthy intestine from a human it's
got a rather small whatever that part is
in the submucosa level lots of villi
lots of surface area after radiation
damage when you have massive cell death
notice that the structures out here are
pretty much gone and there's a lot of
scarring or what's the word that they
use severe fibrosis why would your body
make scar tissue in response to
radiation damage
so anytime your body senses that a whole
lot of cells are dying it's going to
respond by attempting to repair so like
if you get let's say a small bit of
surgery done you could be left with some
scar tissue that's cells that have died
and when those cell contents leak out
they signal to the nearby cells fix
something I can't speak any more
intelligently about that but the body
does and scar tissue is not what you
want in your intestine because that
interferes with what does that Nutrition
uptake as well as killing the structures
that are doing that uptake to begin with
then there's the neurovascular stuff
massive cell death from a huge amount of
absorbed energy can just cause those
cells to die and leak out causing a lot
of edema that can cause a lock and a
drop in blood pressure which is also not
good for you
this could be part of what leads to some
of the unconsciousness if you have a
drop in blood pressure due to any reason
then that could make you go unconscious
and there's pretty much not a prodromal
or a latent phase if you hit the
neurovascular syndrome you're pretty
much gonna go to the critical phase
right away within seconds minutes or
small number of hours they're not a
question why the skin lesions
because mature skin cells live about
three weeks if you kill off the skin
cells in the dividing layer and you
don't reform new ones and those skin
cells die you end up with the grossest
word in this class moist desquamation it
kind of sounds like what it is that's
like sloughing off of skin and leaving
open sores because you don't have the
ability to regenerate that skin which is
normally your first line of defense to
everything and you've got fluid leaking
out and it's just yeah its moist
desquamation why the vomiting well this
question hasn't been fully answered yet
as far as back and i've looked at the
literature around to 2011 there is a
hypothesis that intestinal cells will
secrete serotonin in certain conditions
including when they start dying which
would then stimulate a center in your
medulla the sort of automatic reflex
center of the blank membrane to induce
vomiting why might this be
good thing we're not talking about
radiation but why would you want to
stimulate this vomiting reflux yeah so
let's say you eat a a wet aged steak you
know something that's left out on the
table or in the fridge or let's say
behind the fridge you're left to
marinate in the Sun and you eat it and
those bacteria start killing everything
if those cells in your intestine die
they've got to send some signal far away
to the brain to tell you to get
everything out of the stomach and that's
what happens so the body has developed
these long-distance hormonal signalling
mechanisms to say something is going
wrong expel everything because it's
probably bad for you so radiation damage
to these cells which will kill them may
trigger the same effects if those cells
have little pockets or organelles that
contain these hormones and cause
instantaneous secretion by cell death
that might do the same thing too but as
far as this paper it's a hypothesis it's
not necessarily proven but it does
correlate inversely with the amount of
time to vomiting in terms of dose and
time to vomiting so that much we do know
and then on to the long-term effects
there's two that are really important is
cancer risk and birth defect risk you
won't tend to see this happen despite
popular media but you will see a lot of
bad stuff happen these are extremely
difficult to wrap our heads around and
the reason for that is the population
size required in order to do a proper
study with proper statistics and give
confidence to the saying let's say a
dose in order to let's say a dose of 1
milligram what have some amount of
excess risk you'd need to expose 60 1.8
million people plus a similarly sized
control to distinguish whether or not
point 1 mil agree has an additional
amount of risk so let's say for game
most a whole body what's point 1
milligrams of increased risk dose in
sieverts sorry 1 mil agree
1 millisievert you know tissue factors 1
gamma radiation quality factors 1 that's
1 millisievert that's 20 years of
exposure 20 years of allowed exposure at
the same time or 10 years of exposure at
the same time we're a hundred micro
sievert exposure at once has been said
to say maybe that's the onset of
detectable amount of damage pretty
difficult and our sources of data for
these doses are a lot smaller is that
the key with the exception of very high
radiations than we need to make any real
conclusions the largest sample size we
have besides smokers would be atomic
bomb survivors so folks have followed
all of the survivors of the Hiroshima
and Nagasaki bombings not just people
nearby but in the surrounding
countryside and tried to follow how many
excess cancers were there as a result of
the radiation for anyone exposed within
3 kilometers for less than 5 milligram
so by following this group of people and
finding out how many of them got cancer
compared to control groups you can try
and figure out how much extra cancer was
due to radiation and to graph this this
is actually in the I think the ICRP
publication graphing the amount of
relative risk or to use the words from
the last studies we saw the odds ratio
the o.r of getting cancer an odds ratio
of 1 means exactly the same amount of
risk with vs. without the radiation and
the actual raw data points are plotted
here and there's a couple of lines drawn
through here and this is the source of a
lot of the controversy behind radiation
damage nowadays the black line is the
LNT or the linear no-threshold model
which is a hypothesis that says every
amount of radiation is bad and it is
linear with dose I for one don't believe
this model this is to me a fear-based
model it's certainly easy to make policy
based on this because you can I think
your average congressman can understand
a linear graph not sure whether they
could understand p-values and statistics
but there
have to that's what they asked
scientists to testify about when you
look at the actual data there's this
kind of funky shape line along with plus
or minus 1 Sigma error bars doesn't
really show a linear threshold does it
it actually looks like it might be super
linear for very small doses and then it
tails off and then it picks up again but
this right here is a zoom in of this
data rich area of the graph it actually
looks like for really high doses it
might be a little super linear again
where things get much much worse
hopefully you don't have anyone exposed
to let's say to gray of dose but the
real controversies here in the small
dose region we don't really know enough
to say whether very small doses are
hurtful or not or harmful or not in fact
they might even be helpful so you guys I
think with the first class that I know
you had you last year no guys remember
the answer to what is the idea that a
little bit of radiation might be good
for you from the cache class and you
remember what that's called hormesis
yeah this idea that a little bit of
something bad could actually be good for
you this is also a theory and to my
knowledge has not been proven to be true
but it is evident in some other studies
along with different fields of research
beyond radiation for example there had
been an experiment where rats were kept
in shielded lead boxes as opposed to
just out on the bench where they got
less radiation and the ward the rats
that had less radiation had less
incidence of cancer
however it's extremely difficult to
remove all other confounding variables
from this data that's the trick there is
when trying to tease out are small
amounts of radiation bad for you you
also have to tease out confounding
variables or other things that might be
obscuring your data why the harmonic
effect so what are some of the ideas
behind why hormesis might happen so
there are some theories and some some
controlled studies showing that if you'e
radiate cells very lightly they mount an
immune response there are proteins and
things circulating throughout your cells
that are there too
our DNA and if you stimulate the
production of those repair mechanisms
then the repair will be more rapid given
the same amount of stimulus so in this
case there are let's see I'm just gonna
say proteins I can't say anything more
that will actually travel along DNA
looking for certain types of kinks or
breaks and repair them
if those repairs happen before cell
division than the mutations avoided if
you have more of those repair mechanisms
it takes a little bit more energy to
make them but you also have less of a
chance of a mutation manifesting itself
past division number one so this is kind
of the the cellular level idea why might
hormesis be true because you stimulate
your body's ability to defend against
this kind of stuff and so there you go
cells can actually signal each other so
let's say a cell undergoes DNA damage
and can't divide these cells can
actually send what they call kill
signals in the intercellular space to
the nearby cells stimulating them to
mount some sort of response either
release something or divide more to make
up for the dead cells which could be
good or which could be bad if you make
more of these DNA repair mechanisms
that's probably a good thing
if you stimulate the nearby cells to
divide faster well what are the two
things that could happen yeah more
mutations
why do you say more mutations
exactly yeah if there are cells nearby
that have been exposed or mutated and
you induce faster division you may
induce faster incidence of the what is
it of manifestation of this mutation but
also if let's say a few cells die and
the other ones divide to make up take up
the slack that might be a good thing
this is a normal way that you repair
injury is upon cell death the cells
nearby divide faster fill in the gaps
and try and repair the tissue so it's
both a good thing and can be a bad thing
depending on what the nearby cells have
been exposed to and so there's also this
they call that the bystander effect
where interestingly you can have
biological effects in cells that receive
no radiation exposure if they're near
cells that have received radiation
exposure there are some awesome
experiments showing this we had one here
back when we had a professor that did
medical physics she had created an
accelerator with a micro beam like a
micron wide proton beam when you could
radiate single cells and watch what
happens to the cells nearby so to study
in a controlled way this bystander
effect so if you were radiate one cell
on a glass slide how did the other ones
respond so you know which one was
irradiated and you can watch what
happens to the other ones
pretty slick that accelerator actually
parts of that live on on the Dante
accelerator that we now use for physics
and things but a lot of the parts from
those machines are still here just the
micro beams and the cell parts aren't
and then I highlighted a few of these
passages in sort of the the DNA damage
bystander effect one of the reasons is
when cells nearby divide they scale up
their metabolism they have to burn more
energy in order to go undergo division
faster and that can undergo what's
called oxidative metabolism cells can
can produce energy aerobic Lior
anaerobically when you're dividing very
quickly all of a sudden you start
burning more oxygen to divide faster to
do whatever you have to do and that
oxidative metabolism also creates free
radicals just from normal wear and tear
to your cells and those oxidative
byproducts may also induce mutations in
the same
primary way that radiation does
radiation does hydrolysis makes
oxidative species that damage DNA
chemical oxidative metabolism can
produce the same sorts of things that
can damage DNA in the same way just a
different initial effect I'm gonna stop
here even though we only have a few
slides to go because it's exactly five
of
you